when you you had to audition for Jack  Skellington The Nightmare Before  Christmas right you auditioned for that  yeah talk about a role that a gift that  keeps on giving here's the here's the  luck in my life yeah exactly and that  was the you didn't you just auditioned  you obviously Tim Burton just heard your  voice she didn't meet him right yes and  they they had already done Danny elpin's  songs so they knew what kind of voice  they were looking for for the speaking  part of uh Jack sellington and I guess  you know again Serendipity that I had a  vocal Timbre that that matched Danny's  singing that's it do you do anything  with your voice could you jump into it  do you have a line you could say Eureka  Eureka hello